foreign
last time we trudged through the sewers
of classic Ninja Turtles movies which
makes it sound like I didn't like them
when I phrase it that way but they were
pretty good but I hate leaving a job
half finished when there's still two
left 2014 and 2016's live-action TMNT
films offer a completely different feel
and Vibe than the originals it seems
that they're pretty strongly disliked by
both Turtles fans and general audiences
I haven't seen them in a while and it
feels like it's time to take a look back
at them and see if they're really as bad
as everyone says and if maybe they have
some redeeming qualities
should we give the modern live-action
Turtles another chance let's find out I
recorded most of the script while I had
a throat infection so sorry if that
sounds terrible but first a word from
our sponsor great Shadow Legends
fun fact there are 7.5 billion humans in
the world that could be playing raid
Shadow Legends right now so why waste
time you might as well start right now
completely free to play with over 80
million downloads and 650 unique
Champions there's never been a better
time to pick up raid love experimenting
with cool mechanics and team
compositions raid lets you put your
mechanical Mastery to the test by
crafting your ideal team of Champions
customizing their builds with the best
artifacts choosing their masteries and
then putting them to the test against
raid's many tough bosses and challenges
or even real players learning all about
my Champions studying the enemies teams
and crafting the perfect arena team is
occupying most of my time with raid at
the moment I love constructing a
strategy that is hard to counter
tweaking my team's stats so I always go
first and then researching ways to deal
with whatever is the current Arena meta
for those who enjoy digging into stats
you'll have an absolute ball with raid
raid's got something extra special
happening right now they've released a
legendary champion based off MMA and pro
wrestling Legend Rondo Rousey yes the
Ronda Rousey you can get Rhonda for free
right now whether you're new or a long
time player just by logging into raid
all you have to do is log in and play
raid for seven days between now and
February 28th and Rhonda's yours that's
all there is to it to celebrate Rhonda's
arrival and raid use the special promo
code raid Rhonda to get a bunch of
helpful stuff perfect for leveling your
Ronda up so she's at the top of her game
also if you're an Amazon Prime member
you can get exclusive rewards and raid
right now but there's more new players
use my link or scan the QR code right
here and get a free starter pack worth
almost 30 dollars a free champion Tyrell
and also this cool in-game loot you'll
find your Awards here in your inbox for
the next 30 days only
see you there now back to the video with
modern Hollywood Blockbusters you can
tell pretty much any story you can
imagine in live action but back in the
90s A series like TMNT had some serious
roadblocks that prevented it from being
as big and creative as its comic in
cartoon counterparts its main premise
may be Fantastical and intentionally a
bit ridiculous but it's just inside the
realm of reality that it wouldn't take
an impossible special effects budget to
make it work on some level at least you
can do a more toned down and realistic
take on the turtles like the 90s movie
series but the comics and cartoons have
some wackier material that would make an
MCU movie scope blush with the Advent of
modern effects and Technology it seemed
like a natural progression to just go
bigger go crazier go more excessive and
just see how it turns out in 2014 after
a Hiatus from the big screen TMNT once
again hit theaters through the scope of
a Michael Bay transformers-esque
expensive and explosive film did this
new approach hit big with turtles fans
and general audiences alike
and not really but they certainly tried
their shot at Redemption later
2014's TMNT no subtitle hilarious poster
is a movie that miraculously no one
remembers watching the original
quadrilogy had its problems but was
overall decently successful on each
movie had its own fans yet Viacom opted
for a totally Fresh Approach that takes
the Turtles back to their origin and
brings them into the world of the 2010s
Blockbuster action Cinema the result is
a film that felt like an AI generated
sequence of images based on other movies
that were expensive and successful at
the time with a cast that just seemed
like semi-note worthy names picked out
of a hat Whoopi Goldberg is here except
for Will Arnett as Vern that was
actually decent casting I think he
actually really fits that character
I still remember seeing this movie in
theaters when I was like 15 and not
really vibing with some of the major
creative choices and now today with
added context a lot of other elements in
here are unintentionally pretty funny to
me this movie is a pretty standard
turtle's origin with April stumbling
upon the team they save her and bring
her back to the lair to deliver some
Exposition and the five of them work
together to stop Shredder from doing an
evil thing this time Shredder is going
to use the mutagen that created the
turtles to just
uh make everyone in New York violently
ill and die why doesn't it turn them
into hilarious mutated cartoon animal
people then he'll have his Rich friend
with the same name but anglophied sell
the cure for big bucks it's like that
story you enjoy but filtered through a
few dozen other more generic and
forgettable movies full of explosions so
it could hopefully be the next
Transformers
which it wasn't Michael Bay did not
direct these films he only produced them
but it's so hard to detach the movie's
visual style sense of humor and form of
direction from him
oh monkey was that you pepperoni it
feels like he directed these movies even
if he didn't it really feels like there
was a concerted effort to make this look
and feel like a Transformers film The
cinematography has these Dutch angles
panning shots low angle shots of
explosions blue lens flares and golden
hour orange lighting even the decision
to make the turtles like seven feet tall
and have them constantly doing front
flips and slow motion moves like Bayes
Autobots seems kind of deliberate and
you can't forget filming Megan Fox like
an object and giving the comic relief
character disgusting comments to say
about her
oh yeah Welcome to My Crib girl my
girlfriend's totally the hobo shop I got
a really nice song it's All cued up it's
special girl for us why is Mikey such a
teenage mutant pig here oh she's so hot
I can feel my shell tiny hell dude Jesus
please God stop making the turtles
attracted to April it's always the worst
[ __ ] ever please stop please end it all
into an inner species where these ribs
for months
and she won't do it no she can't do it
the biggest problem she can't hold her
breath long enough you know
the biggest and most dramatic change
from all the previous versions of the
material was the decision to make
orokusaki into a white man born in Japan
named Eric sacks just that name change
alone is so cartoonishly stupid and
insulting
imagine if they cast a white actor as
Blue Beetle Jaime Reyes and his name was
just James Ray
I believe as late as 2014 they thought
this was an okay way to reimagine the
character
all right get your angry comments out
now tell me I'm a snowflake for thing
and they shouldn't cast a white guy as a
rokusaki [ __ ] you
however due to Fan backlash and
accusations of whitewashing they added
some clumsy last minute reshoots and
editing ploys to introduce a rokusaki
proper as a separate character and
remove all the scenes of Eric's ax
putting on the Shredder costume so they
could hopefully trick you into thinking
they're separate characters but it
should be noted that every time they're
on screen together it's in this same
dimly lit room in someone's house
with the shredder actor completely in
silhouette I like to watch this over and
spot all the tiny little ways it's
really obvious that sax was Shredder
all right check this out every time
someone verbally acknowledges that
they're separate characters it's an ADR
voice over added after the fact playing
over footage that they had available you
never see someone on screen say that in
a few hours Shredder is going to unleash
all that stuff you know sometimes it's
just shots of Megan Fox staring off into
space with a bored expression on her
face
you also see shots of Eric staring at
the suit clearly about to put it on
before it cuts Shredder's voice is pure
ADR and we never see a person inside the
costume because there's no footage of
someone getting in and out of it that
isn't Eric's ax
[Music]
also walks around dressed in a black
undershirt that just screams Tony
Stark's clothes under the armor look you
see it right and the Final Cut of the
movie they awkwardly established that
Shredder is Eric Sax's Father Figure and
Mentor despite being 10 years younger
than him Shredder practically raised
sacks in Japan he's like a father to him
sax will do anything for his master wait
wait sax is just an extremely loyal
follower of Shredder that uses his
company's influence to serve their
shared evil schemes sax also spends a
bunch of money buying his Sensei a cool
robot suit
Shredder's design is very reminiscent of
this time period's obsession with
adjusting every armored character to
look more like an iron monger or a
Transformer
you know like Rhino and Silver Samurai
big silver armored bad guys were all the
rage
this actually makes him less
intimidating as an opponent to me
because it feels like the suit is doing
all the heavy lifting in the fight and
the guy wearing it isn't that great of a
fighter
anyone's a badass if they're wearing a
bulletproof suit that makes you seven
feet tall and covered in projectile
knives we've had versions of Shredder
that are literally just robots and they
look cooler and more intimidating than
this the turtles themselves are a mixed
bag I do honestly like their voices and
aside from Mikey's dialogue being
consistently gross in every scene of
April I think their personalities are
written properly
this voice for Donatello simultaneously
reminds me of 80s 2012 and ryze's voices
for him the way they chose to film this
was even a really cool concept having
the actors playing the turtles in
costumes on set and performing their
lines and actions right alongside the
human characters just to have that
motion and facial capture data used to
animate the turtles over them their
suits are designed to have the right
shape and size of the characters they're
playing and it just makes for a more
realistic spacing and blocking with them
April and Vern are definitely looking at
the right eye lines and spacing so you
never get the sense that the turtles are
just superimposed over that scene and
the actors are staring at an empty space
it definitely feels like they're real
and they're there the way they touch and
interact with physical objects including
other people looks really believable my
favorite parts of the fight scenes are
when the turtles are fighting what are
clearly other real people in suits that
stuff just creates a really cool
illusion and I think it's a great
evolution of the body acting and
puppeteering of the 90s movie I'm always
bitching
[Music]
bitching about casting Screen Actors to
play animated characters in big
live-action Hollywood movies but in a
case like this a Screen Actor is
perfectly utilized because he's really
emoting with his face sharing a stage
and being in that location as the
character Raphael's voice has that same
little Reverb from being inside the car
as April and Vern and it really makes me
believe he's in the room with them
you're a talking turtle
yeah now I'm a talking turtle and you're
a human nerd now that we got that out of
the way hit it
ever that accused of being a nerd before
but for whatever reason later in
production they redubbed all of Leo's
lines with Johnny Knoxville it's not a
bad performance but it's kind of a
random decision like you know what why
why why that actor of all the Millions
I was surprised that his voice does
sound correct coming out of Leo's mouth
so it wasn't distracting actually do not
say a word about this to anyone
if you do
we will find you man someone should have
taught Stevo how to voice act so he
could have been Mikey yeah
yeah and then go on to have a career
voicing Deadpool so that character can
actually sound like he's described to
I don't care much for this script
treating the audience like
five-year-olds and having characters
stop and then reiterate all the relevant
information we just learned out loud
like its Ultimate Spider-Man I saw him I
saw that I saw them I've known them
since I was a little girl they were my
pets they were my childhood pets and
they were named after Italian
Renaissance painters we've talked to
death about the designs for the turtles
in these movies but it Bears repeating
that this was a bit of a misstep
I'm in the minority opinion that I
actually think their faces look fine Leo
RAF and Donnie in particular are pretty
okay just something about Mikey's big
toothy grin and humanoid lips has a
shrek-like feel to it and I'm pretty
sure his design in particular is the one
that inspired the most disappointment
and ire of the plans
somehow he looks the most human and the
least like a turtle
so it creates a really uncanny valley
effect in a way that the others kind of
don't
I think they were going for making him
most human so he's the most like
friendly but it just uh it just looks
kind of creepy
can stash Orange Crush behind the fridge
what I'm most irritated by is their
height they're seven feet tall at least
it's hard to remember they're teenagers
when they're three heads taller than a
grown adult in every scene
and these giant bulky muscular designs
don't exactly shout stealthy for doing
ninja things they all have super
strength and make such a massive thud
with every footstep Raphael is
introduced by picking up a giant
shipping container and Swinging it like
a baseball bat to knock out like four
guys imagine seeing the Hulk try to
sneak around on his tiptoes or climb on
ceiling Rafters to avoid detection then
pull out a tiny sword
actually every object they hold needs to
be [ __ ] massive how big are Leo's
swords if like a normal sized person
pick them up the scaling is so weird
Pizza Hut doesn't have a pizza that's
that big I think the look of each
character is really blunt and simplistic
and stupid with what it's trying to say
while also being very visually busy and
complicated Donatello is a nerd so we
gotta give him cartoonish taped up
glasses and strap a million gadgets to
him like the AVGN accessories video so
you're always being beaten over the head
with his personality Raphael doesn't
need to have sunglasses on at all times
he looks like fully upgraded Knuckles
covered in [ __ ] it's just too many
accessories there's this weird
live-action design philosophy that more
details equals more realistic as if
something looking simple makes it look
more fake this is why the Transformers
are visually complicated walking junk
yards with a billion moving parts and
superhero costumes are covered in
textures panels and layers man I'll take
a G1 Optimus over that [ __ ] any day
April O'Neil now has an Amazing
Spider-Man movie-esque backstory where
her father was a scientist involved with
a secret project to test the mutagen on
a lab rat and four turtles I often hear
people claim that she named them in this
version but I always interpret it more
that her dad did because of the name of
the project being Renaissance
I think she was just calling them that
because he did oh wait in the second
movie she says she named them uh excuse
me I named them
so
I I don't know
nonetheless she's secretly and
conveniently the reason they were let
loose into the sewers of New York while
Eric sacks destroyed the lab and killed
her father I find it really forced and
annoying that of all the millions of New
Yorkers to bump into this nosy
journalist that would naturally be
looking into something like this as a
potential story
is also the exact person who basically
witnessed their entire origin story over
a decade ago sometimes things are just
random
April can just be a random reporter who
meets the turtles and is their friend
and that's it that movie worked look you
can interpret the origin in a lot of
various ways maybe Splinter was once a
human Ninja Master named Hamato Yoshi
maybe he learned Ninjutsu because he was
a normal rat that was hamoto Yoshi's pet
that inadvertently absorbed years and
years worth of training by just watching
Yoshi from his cage
maybe Splinter and the turtles are the
reincarnated Souls of a ninja from
feudal Japan and His Four sons that were
killed by Shredder several hundred years
ago
whatever the story is supposed to be a
little bit dumb that's the goal
but all of these have one commonality
they give a good reason why Splinter
knows how to be a ninja and teach it to
the boys henningham just find a book
about Ninjutsu and a storm drain is the
goddamn worst version of his origin
that's ever been told what book was that
the atlas method [ __ ] let me read so I
can also defeat the shredder in
hand-to-hand combat just gotta read the
book
him and Shredder having no connection to
one another whatsoever also makes for
those characters interacting in very
Hollow ways there's all this ninja
battle trash talk and I just can't help
but feel like Shredder wouldn't even
have the respect for this gross giant
rap monster to like even try talking to
him
if there's some kind of shared history
like they once knew each other as humans
or at the very least the rat permanently
disfigured him there's some reason for
banter here is just like Shredder is
being sent in to fight this crazy sewer
rat monster and I don't buy that he'd
have anything to say about that
he just traded as a job
for some reason in this universe New
York is a 20-minute drive from Alaska
and completely Frozen Wilderness for
hundreds of miles the third Act of this
movie is where it feels like they really
started plugging in just key terms in
the script to Auto generate an explosive
climactic action sequence and it just
turns into boring CGI sludge after all
the cool fight scenes of the turtles
interacting with real objects and humans
in a way that look believable the last
few minutes of this are just CGI
characters on a CGI set fighting with
purely animated and simulated physics
and the camera moving in ways a real
camera couldn't possibly move it sort of
takes me out of the movie being a live
action film when the whole sequence
looks like a PS3 cutscene and some shots
just really don't sell visually I think
they could have dialed this back and
included April Vern and more foot
soldiers to at least have some tangible
real-life elements on screen during the
action I think those clumsy reshoots to
get rid of sax is the main villain kept
them from being present though instead
of being the shredder he's just some
dude that gets punched by Willow Barnett
in a little lab he's not coming back for
the sequel overall it's not totally
miserable to watch but I hate so much of
what they did here because it goes
against what makes the turtles appealing
pulling them away from being stealthy
and lean and turning them into hulking
super strong bruisers that deflect
bullets seems like a choice made by
someone who just saw Avengers and really
wanted money
the action ranges from exciting and
serviceable to boring and over
stimulating visual noise and the movie's
Breakneck Pace has no time to ever stop
and treat anyone like a real character
everyone's just a collection of
one-liners and fast editing and whip
pans and explosions and Dutch angles no
one's like an interesting person
Megan Fox is the lead didn't work well
either because her version of April is
just so empty the whole movie is just
shots of her with a blank expression
just reacting to other characters saying
things
you can never tell what's different
about her emotional state in any
particular one of them because it's
always the same dull face
she seems so bored here and I can't
blame her because her character really
isn't anything
she has no Arc she's not really
developed in any substantial way and she
becomes largely irrelevant once the
title characters start to take Center
Stage this wouldn't really improve at
all going into the sequel where she's
not the main character anymore she has
less going on under the shell than in
the last one but that's actually okay
she's in the sequel just the right
amount this is an appropriate amount of
April O'Neil she's got about as much
going on as she ever did in the Animated
Series now and she wouldn't be the only
one
TMNT Out of the Shadows completely
ruined the search engine optimization
for that video game making it impossible
to Google ever again this one is the
anti-secret of the use where the first
film in each respective series was going
for more grounded and gritty approach
and the sequel pulls a lot from the 80s
cartoon it was the secret of the US's
detriment because they took the
cartoon's tone but none of the actual
cool stuff associated with the IP like
giant alien brain monsters and robots
and universe hopping death machines and
a pig with sunglasses there's a really
small scale movie that just felt like
cheesy [ __ ] out of the Shadows
learns from this by pulling tonal cues
from the cartoon alongside the crazy
wacky awesome ninja turtles crap you
want to see it sort of helps to justify
their massive un stealthy character
designs if they can also be a little bit
more silly and action oriented the 2014
film has the Foot Clan as just guys with
guns and black masks in this one they're
ninjas with modern day technology
they're actually acrobatic and doing
high-stakes missions instead of like
taking hostages with firearms and
holding them for ransom or something
alongside the improvements made to the
foot the turtles themselves have also
seen a bit of a glow up they're no
longer hitting people with shipping
containers or unrealistically nabbing
people from the Shadows like The Dark
Knight here they're shooting manhole
covers out of a giant green garbage
truck with animatronic remote controlled
nunchuck arms and falling out of planes
with green parachutes and a rocket
skateboard even their designs are less
cluttered this time and Donnie seems
noticeably thinner it feels like this
one knew what it was going for more it
was made by someone who actually gives a
damn about the franchise instead of an
algorithm mashing together Blockbuster
movie tropes
although both of these still feel a lot
like they were just trying to bite off a
previously released Marvel movie yeah
they saw Amazing Spider-Man yeah they
saw the Avengers weirdly these TMNT
movies seem out of date and trying to
copy both of these the week is parts of
this movie are pretty much everything
that's not a mutated animal
you didn't have to include Casey Jones
and they really shouldn't have because
he's a really cool character and
everything outside of this and I'd much
rather be watching the version of him
from the 80s Show he's [ __ ] terrible
in this cop Casey you that's officer
Jones
and I'm going to be a detective someday
yuck even wearing his hockey mask he
just looks wrong I know it was
redesigned to be like an actual hockey
mask that someone in real life could
wear but it just looks too big for his
head and he doesn't seem intimidating
wearing it at all he never even gets
injured while wearing it to begin with
so it could have just been cosmetic
anyway and he only wears the [ __ ]
thing for one scene great
Stephen Amell is also a really poor fit
for that character
he's not like a lovable dumb tough guy
like Casey he doesn't have big himbo
energy I have this feeling he's not
taking the movie he's in seriously so
he's always smiling while delivering
lines where he shouldn't be pick up your
bow and arrow and get the [ __ ] out of
here you don't belong here this movie
could have gone from like a five to an
eight if you just cut him out entirely
he's the worst in every scene he's in
Kino could mop the floor with this
[ __ ] and I cheer for him like he was
an MCU Cameo I clapped I clapped when I
saw it shredder has been recast with a
much younger actor Brian T for more of
an 80s cartoon Shredder feel
his cybernetic CGI garbage suit has been
replaced with a bland looking colorless
CW costume I think the way the shredder
was handled in this movie is also
pretty embarrassing he never shares a
single scene with the turtles
he never fights them or even talks to
them in fact he never talks to or
interacts with any of the protagonists
at all after the car chase sequence he's
just standing around the whole movie
doing whatever dumb [ __ ] Krang asked
him to earlier without a second thought
and then in the one scene where he's
about to fight he gets Frozen and locked
away for sequel bait that never worked
out I have no idea why he's even in this
movie if he was going to be so
unimportant I actually really like Brian
T too I think he could have kicked ass
as this character you ever see him in
that Mortal Kombat legacy show is an
evil version of Liu Kang that was cool
he wears his helmet for like one scene
in this whole movie and the helmet
covers way too much of his face
so let me get this straight Shredder's
voice comes out of this helmet crystal
clear as day when he speaks no one will
ever know who you are but Casey's masks
with the three holes in front of his
mouth is muffling his voice what's your
name
what's that Casey Jones oh
Casey Jones what the [ __ ] I know this is
a nitpick but come on man sound design
is important don't half-ass that it's
hard to be immersed in a movie when
there isn't consistency with those
things it makes the world feel
artificial Krang is here for a solid 45
seconds of screen time and everything
about his inclusion feels really rushed
and underdeveloped his alliance with
shredder happens so fast it's
mind-boggling the scene where they meet
and he explains his plan is one of the
most insane I've ever seen put to film
it's so fast and just bombards you with
information and he just says like 80
paragraphs of [ __ ] in like 10 seconds
and I can't keep up with it at all and
the Shredder's like yeah I'm down that
is the most out of breath Exposition
dump ever delivered and having it
dropped by a massive CGI brain monster
in a robot in a spaceship after how
toned down the first movie was is just
crazy when you watch these back to back
Wards I'm interested I will help you
take down planet Earth
[Music]
holy [ __ ] crying is also really only
here to have a giant blue laser shoot up
into a portal in the sky and drop in
flying mechanical [ __ ] to look like The
Avengers the Technodrome is already
pretty much a death star but having it
float and be completely gray is a step
too far it should have rolled in on the
ground through a big triangle portal
that opened on the street this final
sequence is even worse CGI sludge than
the first one because they're fighting
another big gray villain in a big gray
room with a big gray sky and nothing
looks real or like it has any color
this fight sequence really just looks
like a washed out 2010 video game
there's just so much here that doesn't
work but this movie has pretty long
stretches of run time that I do love the
screen just lights up with joy and
excitement when the turtles themselves
are on screen and interacting with each
other they're fun and energetic their
humor is more appropriate for their
characters they have more depth to their
personalities this time around watching
them is such a delight in their fight
with Bebop and Rocksteady Midway through
is the highlight of the film for
whatever reason this is the scene where
the VFX are at their strongest in the
fight choreography is really exciting
but for the rest of the movie it's [ __ ]
like Casey Jones and the Foot Clan
fighting and it has a billion Cuts
because no one on set knew how to make a
good action scene without help from a
team of animators Jesus Christ watchings
makes me want to throw up
so bombastic and shaky and stupid
whenever the turtles aren't on screen
all other characters should be asking
where are the turtles because there's no
movie without these guys it's a good
thing that the most interesting
characters are the ones in the title but
it feels like such a drag whenever a
human being has to do or say something
and you just want them to get off screen
as fast as possible
Bebop and Rocksteady are awesome in this
I think it's funny how they show up
whenever Kevin and Peter don't have a
say in the script Peter Laird was pretty
active with that 2003 cartoon and they
never even looked at a rhino
having them feel so pulled directly from
the animated show was really fun gave
this movie a little bit more life and
excitement than the first one did I
don't think they really need to be like
10 feet tall and throw cars though
that's a bit excessive Johnny Knoxville
did not return to reprise his role as
Leonardo but the body actor and now the
new voice Pete plazak sounds really
similar it's pretty much the same voice
but younger sounding so it's actually
better I think okay what I want to know
is
Portal's gonna open up what's coming
through from the other side the big
emotional conflict in this one is that
the turtles are once again feeling
stifled by having to constantly hide
themselves and never interact with
people or go outside in the daytime
around the midpoint of the film Donnie
discovers he can use the tcri mutagen
ooze to potentially mutate them into
humans so that they can have normal
lives and it causes a rift in the group
because Leo thinks it's a bad idea while
Raph and Mikey want to give it a shot
like there was some much earlier draft
of the script where this conflict was
more fleshed out and had one or all of
them actually go through with the
transformation but in the final edit
they sort of get over it and abandon the
thought for no real reason after a lot
of arguing and they don't have a scene
of like coming together and finally
getting on the same page first rapidly
are mad at each other which mostly stems
from Leo being a poor leader in this
movie then randomly after a fight with
Bebop and Rocksteady they all start
fighting each other over like nothing
and then it comes time to finally decide
what's done with mutagen and Leo's like
alright guys whatever you want and RAF
decides they should just drop it it
feels like there's a scene missing it's
all swept away a little too easily but
it was at least a halfway interesting
idea that no other Turtles media has
really touched on before same goes with
Leo being a poor leader which isn't
really explored often but is also kind
of half-baked Raphael almost feels like
he could have been better at it in this
version since he's actually the one who
tries to confront Leo to talk out the
problem and then like Leo shuts him out
after justifying wanting to lie to his
brothers he's kind of being an [ __ ]
for half of this movie and you can't
really get on his side what about Mikey
if you don't get a vote there's only one
vote that counts in this family mine oh
and uh Baxter Stockman in this movie he
doesn't really do much I'm just glad
he's here though and I like his bow tie
we needed something to balance out
stupid [ __ ] Casey
does Eric sacks not even get mentioned
in this movie what the hell maybe these
Turtles are also connected to a Batman
Universe and the Joker shot him between
movies or something I don't know he's
gone
Out of the Shadows is like a really
messy shitty movie but there's some
really good stuff in there that I want
to see more of you can feel that there
was some passion somewhere behind the 30
faceless Studio Executives trying to
make it in every Marvel movie that
released in the previous five years that
first one felt like scenarios and
visuals you've seen a million times
before crammed into a soulless movie
written by three people solely to
capitalize on an IP this one makes use
of the source material in a way that can
deliver some uniquely Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles paraphernalia in a way
that nothing else released theatrically
in 2016 could have
companies that own all the characters we
love can sometimes be really out of
touch and ignorant of what they hold
they'll try to shape and mold what they
have into something it isn't purely
based on whatever is a current Trend
while forgetting that people are going
to see it anyway based off the property
if I wanted to see a movie that felt
more like a Batman or Spider-Man movie I
would have just gone to see one of those
but I came for Turtles damn it I like
turtles
and I'm glad they realized that this
time but it was too little too late if
this was the first one in this trilogy
there may have actually been a Trilogy
the first movie was just barely
successful enough to Warrant a second
one but so mind-numbingly awful that it
scared everyone away from seeing that
sequel public opinion on this outing is
so overwhelmingly bad even almost a
decade later so this series will
probably never see a secret Legacy film
like that first one looking forward it
seems like TMNT will be in some capable
hands for their next theatrical endeavor
Seth Rogen has proved himself a few
times as a reliable seemingly Hands-On
producer over at Amazon with invincible
and the boys
Rogan is the perfect age to have grown
up with these characters and with rumors
the turtles being more of an
amalgamation of everything we've seen
before personality wise sounds like
there will be a lot of love for the
franchise behind that project Turtles
hit highs and lows it's a series that
rises and sets it has two not so awesome
movies in a row and then a pretty good
animated one so let the cycle continue
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles follow me on
patreon
turtle power
[Music]